with all of the gunfire explosions and
other chaos and extraction too it
wouldn't be a surprise if you missed a
few of the quieter or subtler moments
don't worry we're here to help warnings
spoilers ahead
many fans were confused when extraction
2 was first announced and producers
Anthony and Joe Russo made clear that it
would be a sequel that's because at the
end of extraction Tyler rake has left
for dead and it doesn't seem like
there's any way he could survive no
matter what little OB Sees at the
swimming pool still rake is back in the
beginning of extraction 2 recreates the
first film's ending to show us how he
made it out alive if you weren't paying
close attention during this sequence you
might have missed the fact that he
appears to have been in a coma for
several months watch closely during
rake's time in a hospital bed and you'll
notice the attending nurses trimming his
beard and clipping his nails while he's
in a coma it's a quick Montage but it's
enough to suggest that rake spent more
than a few days or even weeks in the
hospital close to death this is
supported by the fact that even Yaz
feels that Nick should pull the plug and
let rake die in peace
he wanted to pull the plug nah that's my
shoes he would have been doing me a
favor
it's unlikely that they'd consider
taking their friend off life support if
he was in a coma for mere days but when
you realize he's been unconscious for
months their conversation starts to make
a lot more sense eventually rake
recovers and spends several more months
recuperating with Nick noting that it
has been nine months since the attack on
the bridge
hardened Killers paid assassins and
deadly mercenaries like Tyler rake and
his team often operate with their own
moral code break has proven he's more
than just a contract Killer by helping
the young boy Obi even when his clients
is unable to pay for his services but
rake and his team also show they're a
different breed of Merc with the cars
they drive that's because if you look
closely you'll notice that Nick Khan is
behind the wheel of a Volkswagen id4 EV
first introduced in 2020 the id4 is a
mass-market electric car with an
eco-friendly interior and a crossover
SUV sedan normally priced in the Forty
thousand to fifty thousand dollar price
range it was also named World Car of the
Year in 2021 and was called the backbone
of sustainable emission-free Mobility by
topspeed.com the Volkswagen id4 might
stand out as somewhat unusual for Nick
and Yaz who normally use only the best
and often most expensive equipment known
to those in their line of work however
it's possible that in varying rake to
his isolated cabin they wanted to be
somewhat less conspicuous than usual
actor Chris Hemsworth has made a name
for himself playing Fantastical
characters this includes of course his
role as Thor in the MCU but it also
includes his part as the legendary
Huntsman and Snow White and Huntsman and
23rd Century Starfleet officer George
Kirk in 2009 Star Trek but an extraction
in its sequel Hemsworth plays a role at
least somewhat closer to home Tyler rake
is an Australian native just like
Hemsworth an extraction 2 we get our
first look at what Tyler rake is like in
his personal life and the Glimpse
reveals some details he has in common
with Chris Hemsworth while he's
recovering in his cabin rake is seen
taking in an Australian football league
game and the one he's enjoying is no
random matchup in fact it's a game
between the Brisbane Lions and the
Western Bulldogs fans of Hemsworth might
know that the actor is an avid supporter
of Western he often posts his love for
the team on social media and in
September of 2021 even posted an
over-the-top shirtless reaction to the
Bulldogs win over Brisbane which is the
same game that Tyler rake watches in
extraction 2. Tyler rake does more than
just watch football while recovering
from his injuries he also spends time
ice fishing and playing with his dog but
when Nick and Yaz leave him with several
of his personal effects he also spends
some time reminiscing about his old Life
opening up a box of letters he fishes
out some correspondence from his ex-wife
Mia who we never meet in the first film
all we know from that movie is that he
once had a child who died very young and
he wasn't there when he passed away the
guilt of that experience has haunted
rake since but while the film shows rake
reading a letter from Mia it doesn't
Linger on the missive if the scene is
paused however the letter can be read in
full and it reveals some important
information that becomes clearer later
in the film it opens with Mia admitting
to having trouble writing the notes and
she reveals that she doesn't blame her
ex-husband for leaving more than that
though Mia tells rake to move on with
his life and not bear the guilt of
having left them before their son's
death she says that their son never saw
his father as a disappointment ending
the letter with a touching note that
Tyler was his son's hero
beyond the letters that rake on Earth
from his ex-wife he also discovers a
small flash drive it's full of old home
movies of his life prior to becoming a
mercenary the whole movies show us
rake's wife for the first time as well
as footage of their young son playing on
a beach before his terminal illness if
you remember the first Extraction movie
these images may ring a bell that's
because flashes of imagery from those
home movies were shown in extraction
looking closely there are flashbacks to
that same Beach outing for the rake
family with her son running along the
surf this time however we're given more
context which comes up later in the film
though we don't see it in the whole
movie their day at the beach was also
spent with rake's sister-in-law and her
young son Sandro who rake must now fight
to protect
extraction in 2020 gave us very little
information on the early days of Tyler
rake most of what we knew about this
mysterious enigmatic figure involved how
lethal he could be all we learn about
his private life from the first movie is
that he once had a wife an extraction 2
we finally meet her in the flash when
she shows up on screen she is played by
actress Olga kurlenko viewers who have
seen krolinko in other movies might not
recognize her in extraction 2 she has
long flowing hair instead of the shorter
cropped Cuts she sported in Quantum of
Solace and Oblivion curlingko also has a
connection to the MCU the actress played
the role of Taskmaster in 2021's Black
Widow though she has so little dialogue
and so few minutes unmasked on screen
that you might not have recognized her
in that film at all
at the beginning of extraction 2 Tyler
rake is still in the hospital unable to
walk and using a wheelchair to get
around visited by his colleagues Nick
and Yaz rake is wheeled around the
hospital grounds and chides Yaz and Nick
about not letting him die in peace when
we see Yaz though he's wearing a very
fancy silk shirt and rake pokes fun at
the ostentatious piece of attire as
remarks that he'll get tyler1 just like
it and that's exactly what he does what
rake doesn't realize is that the shirt
is no ordinary piece of clothing when
rake is visited by Idris elba's shadowy
unnamed agent a little later we discover
that rake is given the shirt to his dog
which Alba's character notices
it's that dog wearing a Valentino shirt
yeah
that's when eagle-eared audiences will
realize just how pricey the piece of pup
clothing is Valentino's silk shirts can
regularly run as high as fifteen hundred
dollars with some fetching as much as
two thousand dollars given the high
price these mercenaries charge for their
services with their fee being Out Of
Reach even for a powerful drug lord in
the first movie it makes sense that Yaz
would settle for nothing less than the
finest clothes that money can buy
extraction was directed by Sam Hargrave
who clearly put his experience as a
stunt coordinator on movies including
Avengers end game and atomic blonde to
good use this included filming an
astonishing action sequence that used
visual trickery and impressive stunt and
camera work to create the illusion of an
uninterrupted sequence in one of the
movie's climactic action sequences in
the sequel though Hargrave topped
himself with an even more impressive
action scene that jumps from location to
location beginning in a Georgian prison
the sequence kicks off when Tyler's
Rescue of his sister-in-law niece and
nephew is noticed by other prisoners a
cell doors open and dangerous criminals
are set loose rake must protect the
three innocent lives from a prison riot
this includes a vicious fight with a
deadly Gangster and a brutal melee in a
prison yard where rake battles both
hardened killers and Riot police
eventually with help from Nick and Yaz
the trio manages to escape the prison
when it's not over yet the action moves
seamlessly into a guns blazing car chase
through a winter Forest where they're
hounded by heavily armed gunmen on
motorcycles before their truck is
obliterated and they're cornered in a
steel mill evading their sewers rate
gets his family onto a moving train
where they come under assault from an
attack helicopter rake destroys it with
a massive m240 machine gun before the
action comes to an end it's all so well
executed that you might not have noticed
that the entire sequence runs an
eye-popping 20 minutes in extraction
Tyler rake is hired to rescue the
kidnapped son of a jailed crime Lord
which takes him from Australia to
Bangladesh the sequel extraction 2 gives
rake a new more personal assignment he
has to rescue his ex-wife's sister and
her two young children who are being
held in a Georgian prison his former
sister-in-law's husband is a notorious
Crime Boss and brother to the movie's
main villain zurab a brutal Tyrant Zoo
rap is a tragic figure in some ways he
was raised with his younger brother by a
dangerous and violent gang leader to
survive the streets of Yerevan they turn
to a life of crime throughout the films
your ab is seen with a hearing aid and
it's during a brief flashback that
audiences get a subtle detail about why
he needs the device in the first place
while mourning the death of his brother
at the hands of Tyler rig zurab
remembers how their father would
discipline him for not protecting his
younger brother during one violent
confrontation after he failed to prevent
his little brother from being abused by
a schoolyard bully zurab is beaten by
their father look closely and you'll see
a long stream of blood coming from Young
zurab's ear which then Cuts directly to
his hearing aid back in the present day
for many in Hollywood getting large
tattoos can be a risky move because they
require extensive makeup to cover up on
film thankfully for Star Chris Hemsworth
his character Tyler rake is just the
kind of man who'd be adorned in body ink
of which we see plenty in the extraction
films we get a glimpse that rake's large
back tattoo that depicts a series of
Norse runes which was designed for the
movie but in extraction 2 we see a
series of tattoos on rake that are much
more personal the scene in question has
rate cleaning up his wounds after a
bone-crunching fights and he holds out
his left arm on the inside of his
forearm we see three small figures but
they don't have any Norse meaning this
time around these are Hemsworth's real
tattoos and they have quite a unique
origin according to the actor in an
interview with Men's Health those three
symbols a pair of uneven geometric star
patterns and a strange web-like wheel
were actually designed by his daughter
India it was up past her bedtime while
he and a friend were brainstorming ideas
for his next tattoo
across two Todd Adventures Tyler rake
has used every weapon at his disposal
from small Firearms to big machine guns
and from knives and axes to a flaming
fist but of the climax of extraction 2
when he has a one-on-one Showdown with
zurab rake reaches for another weapon
that bans up Chris Hemsworth will
recognize it happens in a blink and
you'll miss it moments but while facing
off with zurab rake loses his gun and
looks for anything he can use as a
weapon what he finds is a hearty Hammer
that's reminiscent of another weapon the
actor has wielded before a clear tip of
the cap to Hemsworth's role as Thor in
the MCU the hammer that rake tries to
grab Bears a strong likeness to mjolnir
with its block Hammer profile and long
wooden handle unfortunately rake lacks
Thor's ability to summon the hammer from
afar and zurab is able to strike him
with a makeshift weapon of his own
before he can reach it
thank you